hey friends welcome back to the deep
dive snippet this is a clip from my
conversation with julian hearn the
founder of the 250 million dollar
company huel and here we're talking
about the idea of company culture and
how to keep people in your own company
in your own team happy healthy and
productive so if you're a manager or
leader of any kind then hopefully you'll
find this useful how do you how do you
think about things like culture like
culture is one of these big words
everyone everyone talks about yeah
what's the sort of culture that you're
trying to make it heal and i guess how
do you
how do you mold it in that direction so
i think culture is yeah i think it's
uh super super important and super
important to give it to you care and
attention it will happen naturally
but i think uh the hardest culture will
probably be a company that's been
existing for a very long time i've
worked to places and once you've got a
culture it's very hard to change that
culture luckily with your because i
started with a blank sheet of paper
and i was a founder and i was there i
think it's been fairly
easy to do in some ways because
i didn't start this company just to make
money i wanted something i was really
proud of i wanted a company where i was
going to work there as well so it's very
easy to sort of say i want to work
somewhere where i'm yeah there's no
dicks i want to work place where people
are nice
and i want but i want to perform i want
to get good results to create a culture
where um we we are you know market
leader we achieve great things but we
don't burn people out and people don't
want to leave every two years because
it's such a soul-destroyed place to work
you know they they don't there's no
fights there's no crying in the office
you don't want any of that so we want to
really look after people but we don't
want to have we want to have that energy
and that that sort of passion to achieve
great things and so have higher targets
so try to merge those two together so
sort of stuff that we do is we do
recruit well i think that we do
have ambitious targets but not not so
ambitious you're never going to achieve
any of them
um
we do look after people we have a people
team
that people team look after the team and
make sure there's anybody with any
problems we do provide a lot of perks
she always got share options
quite generous share options as well
and so again we're all
hopefully
more on the level playing field together
and rolling in the same direction
and then we do lots of additional perks
like we've got gym at work we bring in
the pt we have
you know free shield around the office i
went to a posh office the other day a
very
rich company they're charging one pound
eighty for a coffee don't have to do it
you know even stuff like that i think
makes a difference we've you know we
really try and think about doing the
right thing at all times nice
that's really cool yeah i think that's
one thing we're starting to think about
a lot harder now that the team has sort
of sort of accidentally become 17 people
who are like all right now we need to
really think hard about this culture
thing and have you written anything down
uh we've got core values and stuff but
they're all very rough first drafty but
no we haven't really really written down
any cultural principles yeah i would
start it yeah just think about what it
is and words that you may use and
phrases you may use just write it down i
mean i couldn't probably could send you
my first deck that i did it's pretty
crude and pretty rough we've refined it
made it better but there's there's very
famous culture decks out there i think
that um netflix one is one that's often
used very long now it's probably a bit
too long maybe a bit too specific if you
looked at the netflix one did a crude
version of that a quick crude version um
talk about you know principles some
stuff
stuff you don't want to do the stuff you
do want to do um
but yeah so we have two sets we have uh
in terms of values we have uh shaw's
dna's us as a company so nutrition first
tastes the close second
and then we have how to be a huligan
which is what we sort of call all of our
customers and all of our employees will
be hugh ligands and there'll be stuff in
there like
number one
is uh make customers happy number two is
don't be a dick stuff like that
sick
um any time sorry just one other thing
on that is um
i still induct everybody comes into the
business and i think that it's very easy
for a culture deck to become dusty put
in a draw nobody sees it
so what we've done is that when
everybody joins i do it so i'll induct
everybody who joins
and
give them my thoughts on culture from my
perspective
so don't be a dick's like you know don't
don't gossip around the office no that's
not allowed i don't accept that if i
hear that you'd be in big trouble
we print out those two sets of values on
just a little sticker everybody's laptop
in the business should have it on stick
it on there when they first join so at
least it sort of tries to keep it top of
mind
and then um
you know then you've got to live it you
have to live those so you don't want to
work right sort of flaky stuff that's
a bit aloof never gonna happen
so just try and remember and try and
quote those things back to somebody if
they're doing something wrong and try
and you know make sure you try and yeah
bring them to life and
it's very easy i think it's healed to a
certain extent we don't have a flaw
which is just from management you know
like james and this our ceo myself we
all sit you know open plan offices all
sit together and try and sort of live
those values together
awesome yeah i think when i first
started out the business though i i i i
came across things like culture and like
values and missions i was like oh what
is this [ __ ] but now i'm like oh
crap i really wish i had paid more
attention to this yeah hey friends thank
you so much for watching if you enjoyed
this clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day